i do cook every single day you know
juice so i'm going to show you how to
make one of my favorite recipes
this is split pea soup with a little
twist
it's a recipe
all right so you know i cook every day
and i like to sort of tip things on
their head and make my version of them
this actually came out of a pandemic i i
there was a day i wanted to cook
something it was a weekend and i had
like nothing in the house and so i
thought what do i have and i actually
had some split peas and some chorizo
what what do you do with that well i'm
going to turn this on its head i have
some onions and carrots sweating in a
little bit of olive oil we're going to
do a little salt and pepper in here and
if you're open to a little heat i like
to do
some red pepper and you can just a
little crushed red pepper you know yes
do as much as you want i'm old my palate
is dull um
once those are sort of translucent we're
gonna add two cloves of garlic
you know you just want to brown it
slightly
and then i have about eight cups of
chicken stock you can use veggie stock
if you want to
now we're going to add some herbs i do
some dried oregano in here
i put one bay leaf which we're gonna get
out later
here's some fresh thyme you can use dry
too if you want and now is when my split
pea soup
goes a little crazy
we're gonna put smoked paprika in there
right why
because i'm going to take this dried
chorizo it's a hard chorizo sausage
right in here our spice is like paprika
chili powder yummy yummy and while the
soup cooks and boils all those spices
are going to render into the broth
seasoning our entire broth then you take
your split peas and put them into this
broth as well
how long does this cook
now because i think some people
are
unintimidated and some people are like
how long do i cook the lentils
i would say a couple hours you're going
to want this okay
so now is when we're going to take our
tongs and grab this chorizo and take it
out of here oh my gosh ross can you
smell it this looks incredible so set
this aside we're actually going to let
this cool the chorizo and once it has
cooled we're going to dice it so you'll
notice right now our split peas a little
chunkified still and you can serve it
like this but i thought it'd be fun to
get this bad boy out you guys ever work
with an immersion blender
oh yeah hey
this is very dangerous and fun but you
immerse it into yeah be careful i was
going to say the best thing to do is
stick it in the soup and then turn it on
yes you don't want to turn on and then
put it into the soup because it'll all
go all over the kitchen yes exactly oh
oh shoot i forgot to take the bay leaf
out oh man uh-oh well okay so take the
bay leaf out that's very important see
what's fun about the kitchen is that it
doesn't matter if you mess up because no
one's watching unless you're on
television so bye exactly
okay so let's scoop up a little bowl
here
okay all right we have our soup here now
we're gonna remember that chorizo i can
never forget it okay we're gonna
we're gonna garnish our soup with it
because just like when you cook it with
the ham hock and bits of ham come in we
want to taste that and then i do just a
little green onion scallion on top i
love scallions because it's gorgeous
that way garnish is
it's so holy um i will say this when i
wanted a little something something in
my vegetarian version of things i would
do little croutons yeah you could do
croutons or you could um toast garbanzo
beans with some chili powder on top it's
just about texture on the top of the
soup you want a little crunch yeah so
drew you think you know split pea soup
are you ready to taste mine split pea
with the pow
how hot
oh my god it's delicious
what are you getting
a nice smoke
a really good saltiness
which i have to say bland sp split pea
is not good this is seasoned perfectly
thank you um i love the texture of the
scallions and uh the chorizo it's really
wonderful this is
i am not bs singing ross i'm not capable
of it this is one of the best split peas
i've ever had thank you so much
well
and it really came out of just
experimenting i would just
encourage everybody out there you know
there's there's classics we all know
them we all love them but see what
happens when you twist them up and
sometimes it's just whatever's in
your pantry i have to shave
i feel like the flavor and the salt
content coming from the sausage is very
different than the ham and i really love
it and there is that smoke in it
like
ham no more sausage forever it was a
whoa moment when i thought of it you're
welcome
[Applause]
[Music]